à côté de ça il fait un petit effet
voilà il n'est pas or il a testé les
cailloux dégâts
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce film est un petit ponton là bien là y
est un petit ponton faut pas jeter des
gars aller dans l'eau tout le monde
bon aujourd'hui je vous parle du nouveau
smartphone de sony directement ici
regardez comme on est bien on a envie de
se baigner ont envie de nager on est au
canada français c'est l'auvergne y fait
beau il fait chaud on respire on
s'inspire et je suis derrière avec les
artistes du magal ça valait guys ça va
ça va ça va c'est la team légal
est-ce qu'on est arrivé aux jeux vidéo
mon autre téléphone vous l'avez pris ou
par le téléphone parce qu'on arrivait le
dans la bagnole qu'on ait versé 950
milles je vais chercher le téléphone je
pense qu'on arrive aux 150 milles gérard
importante et vous les célèbres gueule
ouverte sans surveillance devant avec
des années comme ça crois moi tu as pas
besoin d'ennemis cent cinquante mille
10950 1019 le gard ouais bah dis aux
jeunes à gages mise saaga l'indien ils
sont engagés dans cette base de données
cent cinquante mille merci beaucoup
c'est toujours là toujours plus
nombreuse toujours plus nombreux c'est
un grand kiff
il ya un an n'était pas très très
nombreux on avance de plus en plus à
quelques mois sans bill on sera bientôt
200 bientôt 300 grâce à vous mais si
vous n'êtes pas encore là si vous faites
pas partie de la team de la communauté
abonnez-vous comme ça plus on est de
fous plus on rit yes sony a sorti a
annoncé trois smartphones au mwc et dont
ses trois smartphones
on a le xperia est trois voilages et
soyez en pleine tête ça fait mal c'est
le smartphone entrée milieu de gamme 2
de sony qui peut être franchement très
intéressant alors ça fait un petit
moment que je le teste
il est là il est beau il est chaud
maintenant c'est l'heure de vous dire ce
que j'en pense alors que je vous propose
parce que là on est en train de tester
une voiture un temps avec ma bande 1 va
là ça va les gars j'en profite un peu
avant de parler du smartphone
voilà ça va on est bien là on teste des
voitures là ça va ça va croire que tu
fais moi je sors qui s'offre deux morts
monsieur gros pendant de monsieur mais
en gros ça va monsieur gros je bâtirai
caméra
rouge en épingle à tenir sinon voilà
comme ça rien bien attention une flaque
la mesure où on arrête de courir
on va parler de ça j'ai mes notes qui
sont là comme ça voyez on fait ça en
vrai on se ment partent alors jeté au
niveau du système monde note que je sais
plus quelle note c'est alors c'est pas
le galaxy s disent c'est pas les rumeurs
du p 30 c'est pas one cloche plus j'ai
plein de notes j'ai professionnel quand
même tu veux et voilà sony xperia
voilà c'est là j'ai bossé on
effectivement sur un smartphone casse
intéressant comme je le disais sony nous
a sorti 3 smartphones au mwc on a le
xperia 10 le xperia 10 plus et le xperia
one et parmi ces trois gars de la
quatrième qui arrivait un peu moins haut
de gamme un peu moins spéculer c'est le
xperia l3 celui là alors est-ce qu'au
final ce smartphone peut être
intéressant c'est le successeur du l1 et
de l2 et au final dans cette gamme est
ce que sony peut réussir son pari s qui
surtout sony peut se battre face à la
concurrence chinoise ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
[Musique]
le premier truc assez intéressante aux
smartphones c'est le format compact il
tient franchement bien dans la main ce
qui est marrant c'est que vous avez ici
un petit bouton pour l'allumer et en
dessous un bouton au niveau du lecteur
d'empreintes digitales dont vous avez le
bouton pour allumer le lecteur
d'empreintes digitales
on a l'impression que c'est un petit peu
un doublon parce que lorsque je le
prends que j'appuie sur le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
ça me loue salle déverrouille par contre
pour les thèmes des boutons je sais pas
si je l'utilisé le bouton pour
l'éteindre
peut-être dans certains cas on a
l'impression quand même que bon voilà de
ce point de vue là je sais pas si c'est
vraiment hyper hyper pratique ça
beaucoup de sens dessous le bouton de
volume
il est compact et léger il fait 156 g on
est un doux en plastique on aimera on
aimera pas je pense que pour des
questions coup forcément ça baisse un
peu l'addition à côté de ça il fait un
petit effet voilà il n'est pas or il a
laissé les cailloux je les gardais ça
suffit en basse laprise diack qui se
trouve juste la soul dessous vous le
recharger en usb sais je vous parle à
tous nos vies dans quelques instants et
vous avez un haut parleur mono et voilà
donc vous très sympa ici le petit coin
pour le micro est ici le deuxième micro
pour annuler les bruits voilà bruits
extérieurs
donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal design
compact il n'est pas complètement
révolutionnaire le fait combien de
plastique c'est pas forcément c'est être
le plus séduisant
néanmoins ça fonctionne d'autant plus
qu'on sait qu'on mettra une coque de
protection pour éviter d'abîmer donc ça
fonctionne recule un peu
ok on attend recule encore
tu crois que je ne vois pas qui est en
même temps on a un écran nova la faire
sérieusement cette vidéo on a un écran
de 5 7 pouces cdu h 10 + pas de full hd
certains le regretteront là dessus on a
par contre un ratio 18 9e
c'est un grand standard bon l'écran est
plutôt pas mal
néanmoins la résolution mais pas
complètement ouf smartphone d'entrée de
gamme oblige par contre pas qui est
intéressant on a dû renier la 5e' si
résistant évitez quand même de jeter par
la fenêtre et de me jeter dans le lac
derrière ça vous dérange pas les gains
en termes de performance c'est pas la
voir le smartphone le plus dingue on a
un et llopez 22 médiathèque
ça n'a pas être le truc le plus fou le
plus hallucinant a par contre genève
pour un usage standard pour pouvoir
l'utiliser pour quelques jeux pour des
applications pour les réseaux sociaux
pour faire vos photos ça fonctionnera
vous aurez pas trop de problème par
contre si vous allez chercher des gens
un peu plus gourmand derrière ça peut
rapidement être compliqué ça va pas
tourner néanmoins la personne qui va
acheter ce smartphone
elle va pas l'acheter pour la
performance elle va l'acheter parce
qu'elle veut un smartphone sony pas cher
c'est un peu un peu l'idée de ce produit
donc ne vous attendez pas à voir un
qualcomm snapdragon je ne sais combien
dessus un médiathèque un oeil au p 22
ça fonctionne parfaitement bien en plus
de ça vous avez 3 giga de ram 32 gigas
de stockage en natif alors il faut faire
gaffe parce que 32 gigas de stockage
native c'est bien il faut savoir quand
même que l' os prend 10 gigas donc en
gros il vous reste 20 giga 22 giga c'est
pas énorme par contre vous pouvez le
monter grâce à une carte micro sd
jusqu'à 512 giga c'est pas mal au niveau
d'autonomie vous avez une batterie de
trois mille trois cent millions terreur
la recharge adaptative xperia et vous
rechargez avec un port usb c'est alors
en euros qu'est ce que ça dit vous allez
l'utiliser une bonne journée l'autonomie
c'est toujours tout un peu un peu
compliqué parce que vous pouvez
l'utiliser une journée mais ça va
dépendre de votre utilisation
si vous n'êtes pas trop gourmand si vous
n'êtes pas tout en dessus pour regarder
un peu plus si vous allez à fond dessus
sur les jeux forcément autonomie la
fronde comme neige au soleil
en termes de photos en un double capteur
arrière alors double capteur 13
mégapixels + 2 mégapixels le 2
mégapixels sera là uniquement pour le
mode portrait pour avoir cette
profondeur de champ le 13 mégapixels un
grand-angle de 80° avec une ouverture de
f 2.2 alors très clairement en termes de
photos sur ce smartphone c'est pas là
dessus qu'on va voir un photophone top
on connaît vraiment
sony pour son expertise en termes de
caméras en termes de photos si vous
appuyez lettres sur les hanches de
m'acheter un smartphone de sony et je
vais avoir un bon photophone vous serez
déçu très clairement il fait des photos
qui sont corrects mais dans cette gamme
de prix ça va pas être le produit le
plus dingue
donc si vous allez l'acheter à mon avis
c'est parce que vous êtes un amoureux de
la marque que vous aimez sony que c'est
un produit qui vous fait de l'oeil mais
par contre pour la photo c'est pas
forcément là dessus qu'il faudra aller
témoin de belles photos avec le xperia
l'on attend les photos et ce n'est pas
avec les barques sont détruits par les
flots de la poubelle on a pas le droit d
accès interdit aux pontons tu t'en sors
c'est beau
[Musique]
hier c'était un accident j'ai tâché
candidats aussi chez matisse et la
chapelle à l'avant vous avez une caméra
de 8 mégapixels un grand-angle de 84
degrés et une ouverture de f 2.0
on a un zoom numérique x 4 on a bien
évidemment le mode portrait enfin bref
c'est pas un truc est complètement ouf
je vous le dis en termes de photos ça
sera bien pour faire quelques souvenirs
quelques partage sur les réseaux sociaux
mais c'est pas là où on va voir le
meilleur outil il tourne sur android
8 oreo pas de mise à jour prévue sur
android ça y est on à la surcouche
xperia avec haut parleur mono double sim
du nfc bluetooth 5.0 est ici une petite
led de notification qui vous permettra
de savoir si vous avez un message donc
ça c'est aussi assez intéressant le
canard arrivons s'attaquer quoi quoi
quoi quoi quand on était en termes de
tarifs parce que ça s'est relativement
intéressant on voit qu'on n'est pas sur
un smartphone qui étaient respectés
c'est pas là dessus qu'on bâbord à les
performances les plus dingues on n'a pas
les appareils photos les plus dingues on
n'a pas les capteurs les plus dingues
en règle générale quand on veut acheter
un smartphone sony je pense surtout aux
diam
on achète sournies parce qu'on a de
l'expertisé parce qu'on a un bel écran
bravia oled n'est pas le cas ici on
achète parce qu'on a de belles caméra ce
qui n'est pas le cas ici
donc au final quand on va chez sony
c'est parce que on veut vraiment du made
in sony avec un vrai savoir-faire
souliers et la sony nous livre un
produit qui est bien qui complètent
leurs gammes
mais à qui manque au final l'adn sony si
on n'a pas cette qualité d'écran on n'a
pas ces quêtes et d'appareils photos
donc c'est un produit qui est sympa il
n'est pas extrêmement cher et coûte 199
euros d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous
aimez le lien en bas dans la description
donc ce produit s'adresse à qui d'un gir
est vraiment aux amoureux de la marque à
ceux qui veulent un produit sonic sont
dans l'écosystème sony et qui veulent
compléter avec un smartphone qui pas
particulièrement chère et là
effectivement il ya un vrai sens en 2018
il ya une grosse montée de la
concurrence chinoise hong de médina ça
va continuer c'est très compliqué pour
les fabricants de smartphones et sony ne
déroge pas à la règle
sony fait d'excellents smartphone sur le
haut de gamme sur l'entrée de gamme je
suis moins convaincu par contre ce qu'on
voit avec ce seul 3 c'est que sony ne
baisse pas les armes continuent avec la
continue à occuper le terrain l1 l2 l3
cette année ça leur permet d'avoir une
gamme qui est complet de dire ok ok ok
peut-être qu'en smartphone on n'est pas
les plus gros vendeurs néanmoins on est
là on occupe le terrain on vous montre
notre savoir faire et on affiche des
produits sony à tous les tarifs et ça
s'est relativement intéressant je sais
pas vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez seuls trois bien
pas bien on design il vous plaît oui non
vous ne marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire on en parle ensemble voilà
je vous embrasse fait des gros bisous
puis n'oubliez pas de regarder ma
playlist qui se fichent par là par là où
par là qui vous présente tous les
smartphones du moment je vous embrasse
nous faut des grands bisous allez bisous
bisous monde profite et là regardez moi
là c'est le canada français c'est
l'auvergne c'est très beau c'est beau il
fait chaud il ya des canards 1
et puis on avec les copains surtout que
ça va les gars ça va ça s'est bien passé
c'était propre
c'était propre propre et beau propre